[Music]
the first jigsaw puzzle was invented in
Europe in 1760 nearly two centuries
later a Canadian inventor reshaped the
popular pastime his puzzle pieces made
of thick foam rather than cardboard
could stand upright turning the puzzle
into a three-dimensional model
constructing a 3d puzzle produces
impressive results to do so - 800 piece
puzzle sets are used to create this
spectacular castle replica an industrial
designer creates the puzzles
three-dimensional structure an
illustrator uses techniques such as
visual textures and shading to transform
flat graphics into a three-dimensional
rendering the industrial designer
prepares the printing and cutting layout
fitting up to three puzzles per sheet
the puzzle pieces are made from rigid
foam the foam is specifically engineered
to be chemically compatible with the
paper graphics and proprietary adhesive
a technician feeds one sheet at a time
into a custom-designed lamination
machine the first station spreads hot
glue over the top of the foam sheet an
automated arm with vacuum suction cups
lifts a single sheet of printed paper
and places it on the glue coated foam
sheet as soon as the paper it here's to
the foam the sheet is released from the
suction cups then the foam moves under a
roller that presses down the paper as
the laminated foam exits the machine a
technician rolls a tube over the foam
pressing out any remaining air bubbles
to ensure the paper adheres fully in the
development phase the industrial
designer assembled a blueprint for how
the puzzle pieces would be shaped and
laid out that design went to a tool
maker who produced a corresponding
cutting die out of steel knives
[Music]
the dye is mounted inside the cutting
machine
a technician feeds the Machine one
laminated foam sheet at a time paper
side down grippers grab the edge of the
paper pulling the sheet into the machine
the cutting dies slices the puzzle
pieces into the foam even though the
cutting pressure compresses the foam it
immediately bounces back keeping the
sheet intact thanks to a high quality
rubber sheet inserted between the blades
the pieces don't get stuck in the die
the stiff rubber provides counter
pressure to help remove the foam sheet
if the sheet has two or three puzzles
printed on it the cutting die separates
them then a technician places the puzzle
on a semi-automatic conveyor belt that
moves it to the dismantling machine the
machine infuses the die-cut puzzle sheet
with Steve the steam prevents static
electricity which causes pieces to cling
together or to the inside of the machine
the machine separates the pieces and
dispenses them into a puzzle box
a technician adds the standard
instruction sheet and seals the box
the instructions are in black and white
but can be viewed in color online the
first step is to sort the pieces by
color and design and set aside the ones
marked with a red dot which is part of
the manufacturing process not the puzzle
itself the next step is to assemble the
puzzle section by section all the
sections are flat so the final step is
to attach the flat sections to make the
puzzle three-dimensional for an
additional challenge you can forego the
step-by-step instructions and refer only
to the photos on the box if you happen
to lose a puzzle piece you can go to the
company's website to trace the number of
your missing piece then order a new
piece online the company will mail it to
you so that you can complete your puzzle
unlike a traditional flat puzzle you can
move your 3d puzzle without it falling
apart it takes four to six months to
develop and design this incredible 3d
puzzle now it's time to spend even
longer piecing this puzzle together
you